My husband's hemoglobin is 7.8 right now. 7.8 is very low on anybody's scale.
Most
doctor's offices or hospitals will suggest that you get
transfusion or
packed red blood cells when you're
below eight. They might have a rule below eight. Some of them have a rule and it could be below
7.5 or whatever their rule is
but that is very low hemoglobin
that is endemia and
that is going to make you feel like you have no energy.
So they are recommending IPT therapy and
it needs the stubborn to be 8.0 to get this treatment. So their rule is in order to get the IPT
you have to have your hemoglobin above 8.0 in order for us to give it to you.
Because IPT is insulin-potentiated chemotherapy, it's still chemotherapy, even though it's 10%
where they're about the dose of a normal chemotherapy. It's still chemotherapy and it'll still
you know, do a hand knock on your red blood cell content, your hemoglobin content. So
they have their parameters that they want to stick to.
He said he does not, her husband does not want IPT therapy right now. So should he still get a
blood transfusion if he will not be getting the IPT? My answer would be yes. I would do that for sure.
It'll make you feel a lot better. You need to get your numbers back up. It's, you could you,
let's say, okay, this person has been doing some therapies that have been
from the standards of care
perspective that have been docking down his hemoglobin. But certainly that's not the only thing
that is. So have some ademia. Maybe the cancer's goblet of the iron. That's at least a piece of it.
What's called ademia of chronic disease. And
getting a transfusion can really help boost the hemoglobin levels up and it can make a person feel
a lot better. So I would suggest that you go ahead and do the transfusion. It'll make you feel a lot
better.